hello and welcome to folding ideas i'm
dan olson and i'm joined here this week
by rant as mo a que Jaime um thank you
very much for coming on the show thank
you for having me now you uh you have a
show of your own that you do called
needs more gay yes and now I stumbled on
this a couple months ago through through
a message board and I was I was hooked
like I devoured your show the it's a
very quickly paced very quickly paced
sort of comedic tongue-in-cheek look at
gay culture mm-hmm
yeah that's a that that's about about
right and now what was the what was your
impetus behind behind the show you know
really III think uh III I'm making an
assumption here but I'm assuming you
kind of found me through that guy with
the glasses yeah I think that was the
first place I saw you which really I
mean I first got pointing with that
sight through um nostalgic actually I I
saw her like on some video that she did
on YouTube and that's really like she's
really the reason I come back to the
site to be honest like she's I think one
of the best reviewers out there and that
really I mean it kind of started out as
just me kind of wanting to be her I
guess does it with a big part of it um
and just kind of putting together all
the things that lo I sort of liked most
about her show and kind of talking about
something that I am fairly familiar with
um so I did this that first video the
the about ten minute a like recap of
Dante's Cove which is a terrible soap
opera about witchcraft and gay people on
a beach and that led to my kind of I
spent like a days kind of sending it out
to people just kind of I wasn't really
sure I mean part of me wanted and maybe
part of me still would kind of be you
know I definitely would be cool to get
on to the that guy with the glasses site
at this point it's probably not it's you
know it's fairly albiet is not probably
not going to happen but um but basically
I spent a day kind of you know singing
out to people and a cycle after Eltham
kind of picked up on it asked me to kind
of do some more do kind of a different
format which
kind of with the the read the all the
videos after have since then kind of
been um well yeah I mean it's it's kind
of evolved into sort of a kind of a mix
of you know like analysis I do I still
do a few kind of you know movie or
series recaps every once in a while but
mostly just kind of like just kind of
talking for four minutes making some
jokes about just kind of different
aspects of gay culture and you know gay
culture in certain genres of TV film or
whatever or what-have-you
and now the so the format it's actually
gotten much shorter like you said it's
four minutes the originals ten and
certainly stuff on on a lot of other
sites review topi oh that guy with the
glasses they say the most shows try and
veer towards the the 1520 minute mark so
it stands out and it's just really quick
and kind of you know quick and brief
mm-hmm and I think that brevity brevity
works well it it it helps keep the humor
going a very funny show and great points
and now one point that you've made a
couple times and either the first place
I saw it was actually in the My Little
Pony episode we're even talking about
you know that the bronies need more gay
which was absolutely hilarious and my
reaction to that to that episode was
actually um because you your thesis at
the end of it was essentially is this an
indication of greater acceptance of gay
culture within the mainstream mmm-hmm
and my reaction was was almost I
wouldn't say the opposite but much
broader my personal take on it is that
something like the brony phenomenon
represents a expanding definition of
masculinity as a whole for you know gay
straight whatever it's that for a very
long time the definition of you know
what it means to be male it has been
extremely narrow mm-hmm and so this is
basically like it's like okay it's it's
becoming more acceptable to be not on a
type you know anaerobic
a giant wide shouldered
Arnold Schwarzenegger type sure and what
would you say two words that is that too
broad is that inaccurate I'd say it's
fairly valid I mean one thing you find
really like you know a lot of people a
lot of you know men are in our kind of
age group when they were young we would
watch grow up girl cartoons even if you
know like I like a lot of you know male
kids watched my little the like original
My Little Pony cartoon or the you know
the Care Bears cartoons and things that
really weren't even like you know Jem
and the Holograms things really weren't
targeted towards that 60 I work hard
girls exactly at 6 a.m. Jem and the
Holograms was the only thing on mm-hmm
what was the only cartoon it was that or
Jazzercise sure so I'm gonna watch the
cartoon over Jazzercise so yeah I mean I
remember that I watched you know I not
so much My Little Pony but definitely
Care Bears and you know Jem and the
Holograms share early mornings so it's
so you'd say it's just sort of this
cultural carry through with the with the
age bracket then yeah I think I I think
like the difference is that people just
are willing to admit they watch those
shows now um and really I think I think
just this though as far as bronies go I
think there's kind of looking past the
whole kind of gender like this is a
missus a girls cartoon it's more just
kind of this is a good cartoon this is
it's really not yeah exactly
so I think overall that's that's a
fairly positive thing because I've
started to see that you know that it's
like slowly we're accepting you know
guys just guys being guys instead of
guys being Bros or sure frat guys all
right so I think it's a positive all
around and that was kind of my take I
was sitting here yelling it's like no no
it's guys as a whole it's not just gay
yes it is gay but it's guys as a whole
guys as a whole everyone's benefiting
from this mm-hmm
and this kind of leads into into a bit
of the next point and this is more
targeted at gay culture in general have
and this is something that maybe I've
notice and I don't know what your take
on it would be but a tone shift in the
in the attitude of Gabe media or queer
media that if I roll back in my memory
to sort of the mid nineties late 90s
even early 2000s queer media was was
very explicitly like it wasn't just
queer media it was like queer media you
know it almost aggressively not straight
and do you think that that's as time
goes on that's kind of tempering and
it's moving towards more of a baseline
like look we're we're just making shows
sort of I do you have like and like an
example like the queer media like
thatthat sort of late 90s kind of style
particularly and now this might be a
little bit biased because this was the
mainstream kind of picking up on it but
something like oh dang it the
character's name was Jack it was that
insanely popular sitcom Oh will and
great Will and Grace would be sort of
the first thing that comes to mind as a
truly awful example I hated that show
and then on to things like the l word
even even something morally responder or
Six Feet Under
yeah and nip/tuck like early seasons of
nip/tuck so on and so forth if they had
queer characters it was you know hyper
queer I can see that ya know IIIi think
the trap that a lot of people kind of
get into is they they kind of go out go
out with the intention of making a show
about gay people or really a show like
about being gay and they sort of they
sort of focus so hard on that that they
don't really kind of it that sort of
other aspects of the show kind of you
know fall to like aren't like don't
don't quite there's like fur or the show
is exactly we sort of suffer as a result
um I guess I mean honestly I I can't
think of the a tomb of too many shows
that have really kind of been in that
sort of have been about I mean I guess
Glee is is I guess sort of a big one
right now and I think that one is sort
of uh it was III definitely have to feel
that it was made with the intention of
at least appealing Q get gay audiences
to a large extent and you know certainly
the gay character is a is a pretty
prominent part of the show I am very hit
and miss I first I find my
interpretation of Glee is hitting this
there's some episodes where I'm like hey
you know what that was really cool that
was really straightforward they just
kind of it was just kind of there and
then I guess I'm like oh it's a bit
uneven and it's really it's it's a show
it's kind of just grounded in you know
not reality it's like it's nothing on
that show is normal in the way it
happened at all or believable or right
or even sometimes tolerable sure so the
actually I remembered another example of
what I'm sort of thinking is something
like going back to the the doom
generation and what was the director's
name Gregg Araki Araki you know sort of
Iraqis work in the early 90s a kind of
the big you know middle finger to to
straight culture mm-hmm um and do you
think it's it's pulling back I mean glee
is please hit and miss um and is there a
risk that as if it pulls back that it
just ends up becoming normal and is that
a bad thing I wouldn't say so me I
personally I would really like to get to
the point where we don't have to but you
know have a show where there's a gay
character and all of his plots are about
him being gay I think I mean the problem
here is it's really difficult to have a
gay character on the show without
addressing it without you know just
because of the way the culture is it's
you know being gay isn't really a
non-issue yet and so whenever there's a
gay character it sort of has to be like
it sort of it sort of requires it to be
an issue that makes sense and this is
something that I've kind of I tend to
call it the niche trap there's like if
you've got kind of that neat Anish
appeal or a niche care
after it it becomes all about that niche
but then if you focus too much on the
niche it's it's only about that and it
becomes difficult to then expand out
from it but the other side of the trap
is well if you if you don't address it
then you're not moving forward at all
and you're just settling back into the
status quo mm-hmm yeah it's it's a
problem and it's really and it's it
seems like there's not an easy way to do
that just with just how the culture is
set up with I mean I one way to think of
it is um the show Battlestar Galactica
and that's for like rather the the
remake and sort of the universe that set
up it's sort of it's really sort of set
in a universe where you know sexuality
and gender is really just become a
non-issue like there are gay characters
on that show but they really don't ever
even acknowledge that they're like the
other it's really just kind of if it's
really it's like sort of it's a it's
just a world where you know sexuality
just not really considered a big deal
anymore and I know I've seen criticisms
of Battlestar Galactica like I've seen
both sides of it people have praised
Battlestar Galactica for that reason
they've praised a Harry Potter universe
for that reason and there's also been
the backlash appeal saying oh well well
they're they're sweeping it so far under
the rug that it's a non-issue sure and
how do you think how are we gonna get
past that it is just gonna take time
it's tricky I I think I think it will
take time honestly I think I think that
it's just yeah it's it just it's really
tricky just to have that sort of like
yeah I think it'll just take time
honestly I I don't I don't think isn't
he's in an easy solution for it at this
point um yeah it's it's it's a conundrum
so now my thought there would be if it's
just going to take time
so probably over you know we're talking
a time frame of you know 50 years here
almost on the level of like okay our
generation grew up with
grew up with My Little Pony and Care
Bears and then when we got into our 20s
and 30s we're like you know what this
new My Little Ponies rocks let's just
watch it come on
like sure and then so maybe another 20
years from now the next generation will
be like well we you know what we grew up
Battlestar Galactica and you know what
just get over it it was a thing yeah III
feel like it is ramping up like a lot
and just in the last you know to
dedicate few decades like it like in
even in like the 80s like just some of
the shows now they would just be like
unheard of as far as having you know
like a positive like realistic gay
character just do wouldn't exist back
then highway does now you bring that up
I watched I rewatched a bunch of the
first season of perfect strangers you
know we go like mainstream primetime
that that is one of the shows it's like
Garfield or Two and a Half Men
you know boiled down to the most
accessible marketable factors possible
and some of the some of the jokes like
the cracks that they take at queer the
queer community I'm like oh my goodness
you can't say that on yeah and towards
like you know ethnicities and and even
just the premise of the show towards
foreigners in general mm-hmm
if you went in and tried to pitch a show
like perfect strangers today they would
probably just call the cops there's
actually a show right now I forget I
forget the name I think it's Last Man
Standing it's it's Tim Allen's new show
I haven't actually why haven't seen or
heard of it yeah I've heard it's
basically like if it's like one of those
kind of early 90s 80s sitcoms and not in
a good way we're just like deeply
jingoistic and yeah and and and you know
without having seen it I mean it's
possible let's just sort of maybe it's
maybe the intention there was to sort of
you know make that character the bad guy
do basically is sort of like all in the
family type thing where it's like you
know this this isn't how you're supposed
to be but this guy's like this and you
know he's not a good guy because of it
I don't know I without having seen its
hardest
but I did see a show and actually I
guess here's the dark side of it I did
see a show recently fortunately it's
been cancelled out sourced was
incredibly terrible in its blatant
racism yeah I mean III actually I didn't
hate outsource I mean I can see how
people got pissed off and after a while
you just got this really was grating for
me kind of like okay but yeah I so it
was porn I can see to me what's that
also it was poorly written yeah it kind
of helps you know to hate a show when
it's bad on its own merits and and not
just its content yeah there's now I
always feel kind of funny when I have
have a discussion like this because it's
like oh yeah you know I I didn't like
outsource because I thought it was too
racist and and Here I am straight white
middle-class male it's like do do I have
any any right to to say this stuff like
I'd say so
yeah I think it's I mean it's yeah I
would say I mean it's it's is that
there's nothing wrong with you know just
empathizing and I it's I guess it's to
some degree it's um it's difficult you
know kind of speak for an entire you
know group of people like this is
offensive to you but I think that you
know if you just look at it analytically
it's kind of easy it's some things are
just easy to see that if they're
offensive you know I think yeah we
actually went through that really fast
want to pin your show oh yeah for sure
um I update uh usually I post a blip on
Tuesday evenings and there's and it will
show up on after L in the day after that
and I could typically update YouTube the
week after that
so I'm sorry every other Tuesday evening
I post a new video to blip um but if you
want to just subscribe to my You Tube
You Tube channel you'll see stuff a week
a week later um yeah well thank you so
much for coming on coming on folding
ideas it was great to talk to you I I
love your insight I love your show
neither you're gay
on blip TV also after Elton calm Thank
You rant as mo thank you
I'm Dan Olsen this has been folding
ideas feel free to subscribe to needs
more gay and feel free to subscribe to
folding ideas if you're watching this on
blip TV the subscribe button is just up
there in the corner and um thank you
very much for for everything we will see
you all next time on folding ideas